[موسيقى]
وايه اصلا
يعني يقدر مقتدر الجامعه
عندنا يعني قصدي كلنا عندنا في ناس كثير
مننا مش شرط كل الناس في ناس كثير ممكن
بعدها
يعني كم حد يعني كم حد يفكر
كثير قوي
يبقى في سامسونج الاحرام في الموضوع فالوا
الواحد بيرجع تاني ليه
فيه ساينس كثير قوي من حد يبقى الناس اللي
ما رفعتش ايدينا بصوا انا شايفاكم ممكن
بالسيد ديروها لو نفسكوا ان فيه ممكن كذا
واحده منهم بلايستيوه وممكن يكون عندكوا
فيروز جاكشن همم فيه يعني انا باحب ابسط
الناس عايزه تعملي حواليا مبسوطين باين
واقساطتهم واريحاهم طول ما انا بس شايله
مسؤوليات كثير جدا فوق طاقتين يعني مش بس
من عادي الحاجات المعديه لا ده بنشيل
بزياده
شاومي النهارده
فاهمه ان احنا ما نقدرش نقول لا للناس
اللي بنحبهم بس ممكن بشكل عام لو حد طلب
مني طلب لو انا في المدرسه وثلاثه اربعه
وحبيبه ربنا يسعدكم في مشروع وانا عامله
مشروع تاني
عايزه اساعدكم مثلا
[موسيقى]
ده مش واقعه في حاجه
او يعني زمان خالص في قديم الزمان احنا
يعني الواحد لازم يبقى مقبول من الناس
اللي حواليه عشان يعيش اصلا
[موسيقى]
انت وجعتم يعني مثلا في يدي اتصلت ايدي
الشمال مش فاكره قوي قوي الوضع على قد ما
انا فاكره اخر مره هفكر شكرا كنت نفسي
فيها ونتكلم عليها
[موسيقى]
الوجع اكثر اللي انا حسيته الميكروفات
عامله نفس
الحته دي لو لو فكرته في الاثنين عايز
عمرك بصراحه
[موسيقى]
تمام
اا اليوتيوب العمر طبعا كلنا عندنا يعني
احنا بلدنا الاول في الاخير مش عايشين
لوحده ده احنا عندنا احساس يعني اليوتيوب
اللي احنا البرامج مع الناس اللي حوالينا
نبقى
مع بعض فده برده بيستخدم
طبعا كلنا الكومنتسبريستيان مدمر في ثواني
لو حد حاجه معينه انخفض محمد يعني احنا
كنا متوقعين ان هو او حاجه
ساعات فعلا لما احد
يعني معظم الوقت بيبقى يمكن
في ناس احيانا بطريقه بطريقه
[موسيقى]
جاكي شان
اللي احنا بنبقى دائما متعلقين مش مش ده
برده بيبقى مستني من فوق كل ده من الخوف
الاول
للاندرويد
اقعد بقى يسالوه نفسي بقيت الموسم على
انا يعني انا للاسف بيكتم لنفسي في حته
ان انتم
تتغلبوا على الحته دي عشان بتزود بالعكس
يعني انت ممكن
[موسيقى]
نفسي حد يقول لي على الموضوع ده جدا
حد يجي فلو انا باتكلم مع عزه صديق ولا
يمشي غلط لا مش هاقول لها ههه
[موسيقى]
امم
اوحش حاجه بقى هي اخر واحده دي الصراحه من
وجهه نظري ان الاستبسين
[موسيقى]
انك تفضل رودريغيز او ان انا ان انا اعمل
الباور ان انا افتح الاكادي دي انا اضطري
قال لي هو مليون مره مليون مره لا او حتى
الكوره وانا بلعب لا انا ما ينفعش بنت
لا البنت ما فيها كوره وتدرس نفس الوقت
اللاعب انت ما ينفعش تسافر تلعب كوره ولا
منحه رياضيه علشان ايه اللي احنا كل ده
اروح بعد ما جئت افتح الاكمل اا لا معلش
نادي بيقول لي لا معلش اصل الكره البنات
مش مش مش مشهوره زي الكوره الاولاد فمش
هتدخلي لنا فلوس همم لا لا لا طيب لو عندي
انا في ربوراكشن مرعب بقى وبيدمر السيل ما
كنتش هاقوم ثاني واقول لا هيجيء لي
اليسارلوس
اغنيه اكشن انا حطيت الصوره دي هنا
صدقهليه
حصلت معي
انا
بعد ما تخرجت
هتبعث شغلانات هناك عشان اكمل شويه اكمل
دراسات
لما ارجع افتح الاكاديمي يبقى عندي فكره
على طول كده
[موسيقى]
حته ثانيه
بعد ما خلصنا الانترفيوم طبعا
بالشكل ده
خالص قعدت افكر فيها مع نفسي اللي هو عنده
حق او انا عديت من داونلود وسبت الاهلاك
عملت صوت وكان ممكن يختاروا لي بس مش
مشكله يمكن اللي جايه هيحصل طبعا
تعلمت ان انا ابقى احساس ثاني
عايزه سبب الموضوع
[موسيقى]
واعمل حاجه ثانيه
تتعصب اللي هو جميل
[موسيقى]
يعني
ممكن انا كان نفسي ابقى باللون الجامعه
[موسيقى]
هو ممكن تبقى ممله
جلد البعد شويه حلوين عماله اقول نفسي
اخذت كورس زياده
[موسيقى]
مش لازم تلبسي بالجلد قوي
اللي انا لسه متخرجه منه وقدمت عليها
واخده كانت
صيف واحد بس يا جماعه بجد
هو صيف واحد انا نزلت مصر عشان هي اشتغل
الجامعه
اقول لنفسي برده لا مش مشكله
ان انت نزلت تشوفي اهلك عشان تاخذ الشغلات
لو تلاح
خامس حاجه
يعني يمشي لحظه بلحظه
نفكر في حاجه فاتت او حاجه قدامي احنا مش
في اللحظه اللي احنا فيها دلوقت
[موسيقى]
ما لهاش يعني ما لهاش شكل معين احنا ممكن
لماده ديت واحنا بنكتب حاجه واحنا بنتكلم
بس اريد نتفرج على التلفزيون لسه شويه
[موسيقى]
اركز في صوت السكينه ركز في
الغابه يعني يمكن
دي كبيره قوي مهمه قوي
ده اوكي لو عارفه بالضبط
[موسيقى]
انا كده عرفت
جميل قوي فرصه حلوه قوي مكتوب اجمل خريطه
موجوده بالضبط
ممكن اكون في البحر عشان السكه تانيه
تتفتح وده حصل معي بطريقه غريبه جدا اا
لما اكون بلعب هنا في مصر بلعب في النادي
وبلعب في الجامعه رحت داخله المنتخب
وماشيه بسكت بقى ان انا خلاص هحترف هنا
حصل حاجات كثير قوي منها اصابه منها دمعه
دمعه ما ردتش خليني اطلع معسكر
حاجات كثير قوي خليتني اقول انا كده خلاص
انا هاسيب الكوره هاخش ان انا في الطرفين
مش عايزه العب ثاني يبقى انا اجرب ولا اي
حاجه انا هانظم بطوله
في البطوله دي قاب كندا جاي يفطروا لعيبه
عن طريق الولاد سالته عندكم فرقه بنات
قالوا
ايه بس
مستر انا مش فكره ان انا الجامعه رفضت لي
طلب ان انا اروح المعسكر فالدنيا اتقفلت
في وشي وعلى فكره ان انا مش عارفه الاحق
ان انا بادرس ولا اروح الجامعه
اروح التمرين بتاع النادي بتاعي ما فيش
حاجه ما فيش رفض اللي هو قفل السكه اتفتحت
ابنها خالص رسمتها بسكويت عشان فعلا لايف
مستوى مسار جدا
الحاجه اللي انا بحبها مفيش حاجه
[موسيقى]